- Hello all of the internet, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
- We're The Slow Mo Guys,
and yes, it is that time of year again.
We've got another six foot,
giant red balloon here.
- Classic.
Done a few of those now, haven't we?
- Yeah, we have.
- Done you jumping on a
big ballon full of water.
- On it.
- Me in a big balloon full of water.
- In it.
- Me in a big balloon full of air.
- So, what's next?
- Under it.
- Under it?
- I think under it.
So we've got this trampoline,
and we'll put this on you,
and start to fill it with water
until it either pops,
or you get crushed to death.
- Brilliant. I know which one's best.
I like that your idea of
me being crushed to death
is being made more comfortable
by being on a trampoline.
- Yeah, bit softer.
- Ah you'll be fine.
- Softer than the ground,
and also the water won't
pool around you when it pops,
it'll just go straight through.
- Considerate.
It's very considerate.
- Very considerate.
- This is the first in a series of videos
that I'm going to call Giant Balloon June.
Which, honestly I'm
quite proud of that name.
- Well done, well done.
Yep, yep.
- So we'll be doing
just giant balloon videos in June.
We'll try and get a few of them out,
and let's start with this one.
- All right.
- Off we go.
- [Gavin] Cue the sun!
- Oh I'm excited to be doing another
water ballon video actually.
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- It's just like this is
bringing back old memories.
- [Gavin] We're experts
at this, aren't we?
- Pretty good.
- [Gavin] All right,
we're just moistening down the trampoline
just to get the black material cooler,
because it's been
absorbing heat all morning.
Okay so position the balloon on yourself.
- Just on my crotchal region.
- [Gavin] Just cause it's so ridiculous.
All right, here we go.
- [Daniel] Thing is,
I'm not even going to be
getting the benefit of the water
because I'm not going to be in the water.
Could be wrong here.
That's already heavy.
- [Gavin] Is it?
- Yeah.
Getting a really good shot
of my double chin here.
- [Gavin] Well the beard covers it,
doesn't it?
- Not the comfiest thing in the world.
- [Gavin] No?
- No.
Don't think it would be
a good fashion accessory.
Oh, it's all going to glob
over the side of me soon.
I think I'm stuck now.
- That's it.
- [Gavin] It looks like
you've got a big bean.
Does it look comfy?
- [Gavin] It looks quite nice.
Is it cool?
- Yeah.
It's cool without being wet.
- [Gavin] I reckon I'm
hotter than you are.
- You probably are.
Sounds like laser fire.
- [Gavin] Had to get a
higher angle on the Phantom
because he's sinking so much.
Do you think people weigh this much?
How much does this weigh?
- [Gavin] Yeah, people
weigh way more than that.
- How much is the heaviest person?
- [Gavin] Over a thousand pounds.
- No.
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- A thousand pounds?
- [Gavin] Think so.
- What's that? 500 kilos?
I'm going to try and move my legs.
- Ready?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- Right.
- I almost pooped myself then.
- Hang on, let me try again.
Oh, I just farted.
Oh, god.
Oh, I just guffed, did you hear that?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- [Gavin] That was awful.
You over-exerted yourself.
- I almost had a hernia.
- Flipping heck.
- [Gavin] What is this video?
I don't know.
Man prolapses trying to get
out from under a big balloon.
- [Gavin] God,
it's got to be putting tremendous strain
on the springs at this point.
Should we have safety
goggles, do you think?
- What for?
- [Gavin] Eyes!
- Right, if you left me here,
and just turned the hose off, right?
I'd starve to death.
- That'd be it
- [Gavin] Oh dear.
- Oh bugger.
- [Gavin] What?
- I'm getting pins and needles in my feet.
- It's like cutting off the
blood circulation to my legs.
- [Gavin] We're going to have to amputate.
- Aw.
This is definitely one of
those moments in my life
where I'm like, how did I
find myself in this situation?
I might take those goggles, you know?
- [Gavin] Yeah?
- Yeah.
I think I much preferred being in it.
Because it's over my knees, yeah?
- [Gavin] Yeah?
- It's like bending my knees
backwards the wrong way.
- Because...
Because the trampoline does that,
my legs are like that,
and the balloons pressing on them.
Which means that my legs are
like being bent backwards.
- [Gavin] Hup.
- Oh.
- [Gavin] SPF 30.
- Oh nice.
I can't get them now!
- [Gavin] I think we've
got to call this one...
- Oh!
- [Gavin] ...crushed by
a 6 foot water balloon.
- Oh flip.
- [Gavin] You look like a Mr. Man.
- [Gavin] Which one of the
Mr. Men was a red circle?
- Oh! Mr. Amputate My Leg.
Ah!
- [Gavin] It's so big now.
- The thing is, I can't even re-adjust it.
- Ow!
Oh my leg!
It's like, twisted.
Can you itch my foot?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- Ah, oh!
To the left.
- [Gavin] Oh come on now.
- Oh yeah, that's it. There you go.
Sod that.
- [Gavin] All right,
are you ditching them?
- They're just annoying me.
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- If I get my eyes taken out by a balloon,
I want some sort of compensation.
- [Gavin] From me?
- Yeah.
Have you got the good ones on?
Give me the good ones.
- Oh Yes.
You don't even need them,
what are you wearing them for?
- [Gavin] No, I'm not
wearing them for the balloon,
I'm wearing them for
the springs flying out.
- The springs? They'll be fine.
I might have to pop it soon.
- [Gavin] Yeah?
Just for your own safety?
- Yeah, just for my leg.
I don't want an amputated left leg.
I'm done.
- [Gavin] You done?
- My leg needs to, it's going
to come off in a minute.
- [Gavin] All right, I'll get you out.
- Show me how you want me to do it.
Like here?
- [Gavin] Yep.
- Yeah?
Right, here?
- [Gavin] Yep.
- Yeah?
- Yep.
How was that?
- I felt like I was
drowning for a second there.
Because it pops, and
the water went over me,
it went like
- [Gavin] Thoughts?
- Hang on, let me just stand up.
Oh my god, that left leg.
- [Gavin] It gave you jelly legs.
- It did.
Hang on.
I'm just letting the blood
re-flush back into my legs.
- [Gavin] You almost lost
a leg from a balloon!
- Oh god, I can't move!
- [Gavin] Dan, the things you
go through for this channel
- [Gavin] Commendable.
You know when people
take their first steps
after spending like a year in space?
- Like Bambi.
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- Okay, yeah. I think I'm good.
- You can stand again.
- Oh just about.
- I've never seen jelly legs like that.
You know how you see like
marathon runners get that?
- Yeah, I had Bambi legs.
I had nothing there,
for about five minutes.
- God, I wonder how
far away we were from
some permanent damage.
- Oh, it's like your ball
when that got twisted
around its own blood supply
and got cut off.
- Except it was the
entirety of my lower leg
that I couldn't feel anymore.
- God, brutal, and it's
just water as well!
- Well, it's because the trampoline,
it actually made it worse,
because my leg was bent
under the weight like that.
So it was like going the wrong way.
- You can just never
underestimate the weight of water.
Like, if that was dropped
from above onto your head,
it would be like getting hit with a brick.
- It would kill me.
- You would absolutely be killed.
- Yeah.
- Well, that was enjoyable.
- For you, yeah.
- Yeah. Well, yeah.
- Hopefully for them, too.
- Hopefully for the audience as well.
Well done, B.
- Cheers.
- And we'll have to crack
on with the other one now.
- Tune in again for Balloon June...
- Big Old Balloon June.
- Next week.
- Next week, a new
video, a new big balloon.
- Oh god, I hope I
don't get crushed again.
- Follow us on Twitter,
subscribe to the main channel,
second channel.
- Buy some merch!
- And buy some merch.
If Dan sees you wearing that
merch, he will buy you a drink.
- Probably.
- See you next week.